[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
these beasts I'm Sean Evans coming at
you from Brooklyn New York fertile
ground for some of the best pieces in
the entire country now it's no secret
that I've stuck my neck out time and
time again for my beloved
deep dish but today we're exploring the
other side of the debate and to make
sure that we don't break it
we've teamed up with the best pizza
Sherpa in the game Paulie G the pizza
king of Greenpoint and today he's going
to give us the peep the cheat code a
crash course and the do's the don't and
what you need to know to pick out the
perfect light so it's not further delay
let's go find Paulie G
[Music]
I'll Paulie G I own Paulie Gee's
Greenpoint pizza joint and I'm here
today because I've always had a love for
pizza and I found a way to turn that
love pizza into a wonderful life I've
been eating pizza Brooklyn since I was
about four years old when I had my first
slice of McDonald Avenue near church and
a place I think was called Sal my real
pizza transformation started for me in
the 1990s when I started looking for
coal oven pizza would five Pizza we just
went all around and as I was doing that
I observed that Pizza was a very simple
process
I built an oven on my property at home
in New Jersey when I was 54 years old
for a couple of years I practiced that
experiment that I invited people over
and after two years I signed the lease
and I was here in Greenpoint on opening
night March 9 2010 today is going to be
a classic poorly G kind of day going to
eat lots of pizza alright them linked up
with Paulie G brought me out to Bay
Ridge Paulie what the hell we doing here
Nino's is the quintessential New York
slice shop in the 70s I consumed a great
deal of alcohol down the block from here
and I always had to sober up a couple of
delicious slices and I came back
recently as even better than it was next
all right well that's an important note
ready to get it going I'm starving go
[Music]
going you wanted a cliff with New York
slice joint you got these are my friends
Lorenzo and Benny looks like it I don't
know any nose doesn't get any better
than this
what makes this shop so classic what
makes the pizzas so good well I mean
first of all the whole area I think it
became famous when they started with the
movie Saturday Night Fever and that just
like started like a whole thing in Bay
Ridge you know became like a big club in
place and John Travolta goes to Lenny's
pizza you know my father he he was on he
was an owner that's where he slapped 2/3
together didn't like that's right - give
me - in the 1970s what did the New York
slice mean
and if that changed now you think or is
it more or less the same you still have
that traditional New York slice you know
those people love but again like our
taste has change we have multiple
different reasons you definitely should
have additional regular slice you know
and a very much less got that
grandmother so folks don't forget ready
go in business have another glass I'll
go with the trifecta tell me what's a
good slice versus the vast rice what are
you looking for exact it has a nice
orange color to it not too white not too
red there's not a lot of spice in it I
wanted what pairs baths with New York
City pizza fruit punch there it is
maybe orange and then we have two other
sorts of things going on this is the
grandma this is something we never had
when when you know sliced choice for
classic sliced choice usually I'm not
that big a fan this thing serious
business
they're known here now this it's nice
and thin and it's highly seasoned that's
that's the difference between the
grandmother's Cecilia besides the
thickness is it there's a garlic flavor
to it there's a lot of oregano which you
don't get on the other slices and then
we have the squares place here this is
the Sicilian right I ought to take a
bite of this right now it's just a
psyllium a true Sicilian pizza well did
not have any cheese on those just social
call this food Chonan and this is
seasonings on and I think I think Romano
maybe sometimes it was a chocolate lien
Toby in there but this just became like
an American Sicilian slice nice and
crunchy and abhava nice and fluffy
inside watch Polly what do you prefer
corners our side but everybody loves the
corner and I do too but I'm a guy that
gets in the car and drives in these
pizza occasionally when I go back to
Jersey and you got to have a corner
slice for that I got some mark of a true
pizza professional he has the pieces
that he prefers when he's driving he has
the piece that he prefers when he's
sitting now this place is just classic
this is what it's all about this is a
family-owned business three brothers
took it over from their father a
wonderful thing you ready to check out
another place
I am following you ever you want to go
to high very good right now going back
to this slice so we're sitting down
feels like I'm in a bit of a time warp
here Paulie what's so special about fans
that's exactly what so special about
sense an old-school Italian joint just
like it was in 1930 and have great pizza
here comes Lou I don't about it you know
I've been thought of all died come here
for Lou and the clams and a piece
I got no clips why is your pizza so good
but tell me about that up that oven used
to be a coal-fired oven my uncle
switched it over to natural gas in the
40s the oven is still the strongest coal
and the pizzas better than any slice
show in New York
it really is that's that's big praise
coming to really it's amazing pizza
I've had people if they for recipes I
refuse to give it to them my father
passed it down to me and he's gonna pass
it down to me well it's gonna cost you
I'll pay go cause I've got a couple
million yeah I'm gonna get a couple days
ah I gotta charge your rent late look
Shawn heading for very big things and
he's the big clams oreganata right here
gotta have the lemon e yfh Oh everybody
know what that means eat your [ __ ]
heart out there you go oh so by the way
when's this pizza coming thanks trip
next year we can't wait them well you
keep swapping the bread a little well
let's off you could take it bring us the
pizza nice you ready to go let's do it
let's do it let's do it no but it might
be a little hot here you go I'm ready
going in he'll fold
you know a slice Menino's slice here
I sort of look the same right on the
plate but a different taste what's going
on what's the difference in that pizza
business pizza there's more of a Tang in
this cheese and the crust the quest is
very different I mean you can look at
you can see there's something about
pricing you get in a restaurant like
this that having to have a different
quality to it it's not like a slice
joint chillin and this is a perfect
example of great pizza Lou six out of
five six stars out of five Andrew you
know what makes this place special room
it's the way Lou treats people I never
expected that when I came in I didn't I
fight I fight my first night I wasn't
too crazy about four because he kept
scoff at pitches pitches pitches um can
I get another picture here before we do
this any chance we could shut the light
off for a second luckily I found out
okay oh I just thought if I find time to
placate any ice what is worried about
I'll cut your hair well stealing you
stealing besides you're more business to
me yep all right has this been a great
day so far so far so good I slice joint
great Italian restaurant here great
pizza I want to show you my place now
and hope you feel the same way but my
place is I feel about these places I've
been waiting all day to see Paulie Gee's
let's go to your spot alright now we're
in the kitchen at Paulie Gee's and
Paulie the places that you've taken me
today have noticed gas ovens but not at
the Paulie G pizzeria at Paulie Gee's
it's a wood-burning of it the type of
pitch were making here is Neapolitan
inspired which is the way they've been
making pizza in the Naples region for
2,000 years it's romantic you do need a
good thousand degree oven to get the
dough to come out they're loose the way
I like it
- you cook at a lower temperature you
get a crisper pie this is a softer pie
what are we going to do today we're
going to start off with the Hellboy
that's because he he is the spicy guy
okay
and this pie is like a classic pepperoni
pie but it's hot super sada it's
sort of aiya class pepperoni and we're
going to drizzle on Mike's hot honey
which is is the industrial sized bottle
of Mike's honey right here you want to
get to know this when you're tossing the
dough around like this what are you
feeling for today
well the right size we want to we don't
want to get it too big before we finish
the stretch we want to make sure that we
keep the air in other bubbles around the
edge now we're just about the right size
12 inches or so now we're going to take
some sauce my secret sauce tomatoes
there's actually now a fully juiced
abyss we give it a sprinkle of shaved
parm Reggiano we're going to add some
fresh mozzarella I like to shred it when
you don't shred it you get these little
lumps and take one bite and whole thing
comes off here apologies we're very
generous with a hot supersonic that's
the poly G difference right there you go
right there so we have our pizza here
but it's not quite done is it
no one's not we cut up five and six okay
we drizzle on is Mike's hot honey what
have we learned about the evolution of
pizza today
what we've learned is that as we evolve
we went right back to the beginning
because the pizza that's very prevalent
here in New York today is pizza that was
made the same way 2,000 years ago
Pompeii we feel like the only
appropriate way to end this day is to
just do what we've been doing all day
which is eating pizza okay shouldn't
have me the first time serious business
[Music]
thanks for thanks for foot will filming
I'm like a pizza of a picture Sherpa he
called me